this episode was proudly made possible
by Subaru
for as long as I can remember I've had a
soft spot for love and melancholy and I
think those two things are intimately
interrelated right love and sadness
stately they exist in the same space
there's a reason the filmmaker Cameron
Crowe uses the term happy sad to
describe those moments that move us that
swell us that when you're becoming
boards with emotion and we're also you
know a little bit like and not so sure
if that's making me that happier if I'm
sad I can't really tell and Roland
Barthes explored this beautiful in his
book a lover's discourse there's a
couple lines in it that I really love he
says the first thing we love is a scene
which is seen for the first time
curtain parts and what had never been
seen is devoured by the eyes it's
distinct abrupt and it is already a
memory and this is the line that one
gets me its idea that it was struck by
love it is immediately already a memory
the moment is happening and you're
already mourning the fact that the
moment will end this intertwining of
melancholy a loss that is literally
embedded in the experience of rapture is
what serve so unique and mesmerizing
about love but also what makes it so
tragic right there's a reason that
Roland Barthes cites love as the
romantic solution to the problem of
death that our lovers act as stand-ins
in a staged managed resurrection where
the pilgrim without faith can die and
live again these death and rebirth
simulations allowing us to finally the
turn our lovers into gods and goddesses
to be saved by them it's every pop song
it's every romantic movie you've ever
seen you know the feeling it moves us to
tears but who cares because as Khemu
says life should be lived to the point
of Tears so fall in love or die trying'
right
be sure to check out second chance
Subaru at revision3.com Subaru